- Bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo
la Información y Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous, y soy
el Director Técnico de IBM Quantum Education.
Esta es la cuarta lección de la serie y es la última
lección de la primera unidad de la serie sobre los fundamentos
de la información cuántica.
Hasta ahora, hemos hablado sobre
cómo funciona la información cuántica tanto para sistemas individuales como múltiples, hemos visto el
modelo de quantum circuit,
y hemos observado algunas
limitaciones fundamentales de la información cuántica.
En el camino, nos encontramos
con algunos conceptos matemáticos importantes,
incluyendo productos tensoriales y productos internos, y continuaremos
haciendo uso de esos conceptos e introduciremos algunos nuevos
a medida que los necesitemos.
En esta lección, nos centraremos
en tres ejemplos fundamentales e importantes: quantum teleportation, superdense coding y el juego CHSH,
que también se llama desigualdad CHSH y no siempre se describe como un juego.
Estos no son simplemente ejemplos
aleatorios pensados para ilustrar cómo funciona la información cuántica, realmente son partes clave
de los fundamentos
de la información cuántica y
surgen en contextos distintos y a veces inesperados dentro de la información
y la computación cuántica.
El entrelazamiento juega un papel clave en los tres
ejemplos, y de hecho, es el entrelazamiento lo que hace que funcionen
y los hace interesantes. Así que esta lección será, en cierto sentido, nuestra primera oportunidad de
ver el entrelazamiento en acción
y empezar a explorar qué es lo que hace que el entrelazamiento sea tan interesante.
El resumen de la
lección es muy simple: iremos uno por uno
a través de los tres ejemplos que acabo de mencionar:
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding y el juego CHSH.
Discutiremos en qué consisten estas cosas y qué las hace interesantes, y haremos los análisis que explican exactamente cómo funcionan
a nivel matemático.
Antes de llegar al primero
de los tres ejemplos, que es quantum teleportation, es apropiado primero
presentar a los personajes,
Alice y Bob, en caso de que no
los conozcas.
Alice y Bob son nombres
dados a entidades o agentes hipotéticos en sistemas, protocolos, juegos,
y realmente cualquier otro tipo de interacción que se quiera considerar que implique el intercambio de información.
Surgieron por primera vez en el
contexto de la criptografía en la década de 1970, pero la
convención de usar estos nombres de esta manera se ha vuelto muy común
en un contexto mucho más amplio desde entonces. La idea es que estos
son nombres muy comunes, al menos en algunas partes del mundo, y empiezan con las letras A y B,
y también resulta conveniente
referirse a Alice y Bob usando los pronombres ella y él, solo por razones de brevedad.
Generalmente imaginamos que Alice y Bob están en ubicaciones diferentes y que tienen
distintos objetivos y distintos comportamientos
dependiendo de lo que estemos hablando.
Por ejemplo, si estamos
hablando de comunicación, es decir, la transmisión de información, entonces podríamos decidir
que Alice es la emisora
y Bob es el receptor
de cualquier información que se esté transmitiendo.
A veces Alice y Bob
cooperan, lo cual es muy típico, pero a veces
compiten o pueden tener objetivos distintos que pueden
o no ser compatibles
entre sí, pero todo esto
debe quedar claro en la situación que se esté tratando.
Por supuesto, representan abstracciones y no necesariamente seres humanos reales.
También podemos introducir
personajes adicionales como Charlie y
Diane u otros nombres que representen distintos
roles, como Eve
para un fisgón o Mallory para alguien que actúa de manera maliciosa,
dependiendo del contexto.
En cualquier caso, veremos a Alice y Bob en los tres
ejemplos que discutiremos en esta lección y de vez en cuando
a lo largo del resto de la serie. También haré algunos
comentarios sobre el entrelazamiento antes de pasar a los tres ejemplos.
En la lección dos, encontramos este ejemplo de un estado entrelazado de dos qubits.
Es uno de los cuatro estados de Bell, y podría decirse que
este estado en particular representa el ejemplo arquetípico
de un estado cuántico entrelazado.
También encontramos este
ejemplo de un estado probabilístico de dos bits.
Es análogo al
estado entrelazado en cierto sentido, pero no está entrelazado;
el entrelazamiento es un fenómeno únicamente
cuántico,
esencialmente por definición.
Existe una definición matemática precisa de qué es el entrelazamiento, y básicamente lo que dice esa definición
es que el entrelazamiento
es una correlación cuántica no clásica.
Pero eso no es
muy útil a nivel intuitivo; es una definición del entrelazamiento en términos de lo que el entrelazamiento no es,
y probablemente por esa
razón resulta bastante difícil explicar qué es el entrelazamiento y qué lo hace especial
en términos intuitivos.
Cuando la gente intenta
explicar qué es el entrelazamiento en términos intuitivos,
con frecuencia se escuchan explicaciones que realmente no
distinguen estos dos estados
de manera significativa. Puede que escuches la idea
de que si mides uno de los dos qubits entrelazados,
entonces el estado del otro
de alguna manera se ve afectado instantáneamente, o que el estado de los dos qubits no puede describirse por separado
o que los dos qubits
de alguna manera conservan un recuerdo el uno del otro, o incluso que
están conectados emocionalmente de algún modo.
Pero ¿por qué esas propiedades
no se cumplen para este estado?
Estos dos bits están íntimamente conectados; cada uno guarda un recuerdo perfecto
del otro en un sentido literal, pero
no es un estado entrelazado.
Bueno, una forma de explicar qué es
lo que hace especial al entrelazamiento y qué hace que este estado
sea muy diferente de este otro es explicar qué
podemos hacer con el entrelazamiento
o qué podemos ver que ocurre
gracias al entrelazamiento y que va más allá de las decisiones que tomamos sobre cómo representamos nuestro
conocimiento usando vectores.
Los tres ejemplos
que veremos en esta lección tienen esta naturaleza, en el sentido de que ilustran
cosas que podemos hacer con el entrelazamiento que
no podemos hacer con este estado
ni con ningún estado correlacionado clásicamente.
De hecho, es muy común en el estudio de la información y la computación cuánticas considerar el entrelazamiento como un recurso
mediante el cual se pueden
llevar a cabo distintas tareas.
Y cuando lo hacemos así, consideramos que este estado representa
una unidad de entrelazamiento.
A esta unidad de
entrelazamiento la llamamos e-bit; la «e» viene de
entangled o entanglement.
Es cierto que son dos qubits, pero como cantidad de
entrelazamiento equivale a un e-bit.
También puedes ver un par
de bits clásicos ordinarios en el estado probabilístico correlacionado
de antes como un recurso que equivale
a un bit de aleatoriedad compartida.
Puede ser muy útil en
criptografía compartir un bit aleatorio con alguien, siempre que
nadie más sepa cuál es ese bit, de modo que
pueda usarse como clave privada
o como parte de una clave privada, por ejemplo, con fines de cifrado.
Pero en esta lección, nos centraremos en este estado entrelazado y
en lo que podemos hacer con él.
Y solo para aclarar la terminología: cuando decimos que Alice
y Bob comparten un e-bit, lo que queremos decir es que
Alice tiene un qubit llamado A,
Bob tiene un qubit llamado B, y juntos el par A, B
está en el estado Phi plus.
No importa qué nombres
elijamos para los dos qubits; por supuesto, podríamos
elegir nombres distintos, pero a lo largo de esta lección
usaremos estos nombres
en aras de la claridad. El primer ejemplo de la lección
es la teletransportación cuántica,
que a partir de ahora llamaremos simplemente
teletransportación por brevedad.
La teletransportación es un protocolo que permite a un emisor
transmitir información cuántica a un receptor usando únicamente entrelazamiento
y comunicación clásica para
llevar a cabo esa transmisión.
No tiene absolutamente nada que ver con la interpretación habitual
de la palabra teletransportación en la ciencia ficción, que
consiste en que la materia desaparece
en un lugar y aparece en otro.
La teletransportación cuántica es simplemente un nombre que pretende evocar esa imagen o metáfora, por así decirlo.
Lo que se teletransporta es
información cuántica, no materia, y eso ocurre
mediante una transmisión de información clásica
junto con entrelazamiento.
Para entender exactamente
cómo funciona la teletransportación, es útil comenzar
preparando el terreno, por así decirlo.
Lo que haremos es imaginar un escenario con Alice y Bob, y
ese escenario es el siguiente:
Alice tiene un qubit llamado Q que
le gustaría transmitir a Bob, lo que significa que quiere
que Bob tenga en sus manos
un qubit que esté exactamente
en el mismo estado en que se encuentra Q cuando comienza el protocolo.
En otras palabras, estamos hablando del problema fundamental de
transmisión de información o comunicación.
Tenemos un emisor llamado Alice
y un receptor llamado Bob, y Alice quiere enviar
información cuántica en forma de qubit a Bob.
Hay una restricción, sin embargo: Alice no
puede enviar físicamente Q a Bob; todo lo que puede hacer es enviar información clásica a Bob.
Alice y Bob también cuentan
con un recurso adicional: comparten un e-bit.
Ese es el escenario; es
fácil imaginar situaciones en las que la restricción de que
Alice no puede enviar físicamente Q
a Bob es una abstracción razonable.
Si Alice y Bob estuvieran en
continentes distintos, por ejemplo, o si Alice no supiera
la ubicación exacta de Bob, entonces enviar físicamente un qubit
probablemente sería bastante complicado.
Pero la comunicación clásica
no solo es posible sino bastante económica
en esas circunstancias.
Ahora bien, uno podría preguntarse si es posible que Alice y Bob lleven a cabo esta tarea sin necesitar siquiera el e-bit compartido.
Es decir, ¿hay
alguna forma de transmitir un qubit usando únicamente
comunicación clásica?
La respuesta es no: no es posible transmitir información cuántica usando únicamente comunicación clásica, y eso no es demasiado difícil de demostrar
usando algo de teoría básica de
información cuántica, que veremos en la
tercera unidad de la serie.
Por ahora, una forma intuitiva
de pensarlo es a través del teorema de no clonación.
Imagina que hubiera una manera
de enviar información cuántica usando solo comunicación clásica,
pero la comunicación clásica
puede copiarse y difundirse fácilmente, lo que significa
que la comunicación clásica
podría enviarse a dos
receptores, Bob y Charlie, digamos.
Si ambos recibieran la
misma información clásica de Alice, ¿los dos
terminarían con Q?
Eso sugeriría que clonamos Q, pero sabemos que eso es imposible.
A modo de acotación, observemos
que ciertamente es posible describir
vectores de estado cuántico usando información clásica.
Cada vector de estado cuántico
que verás en la serie te está siendo descrito
usando información clásica que fue transmitida al
dispositivo en el que lo estás viendo.
En general, podríamos imaginar
describir el estado en que se encuentra Q usando bits clásicos,
quizás con cierta precisión,
pero eso no es comunicación cuántica, eso es solo describir
estados cuánticos como vectores, y volveremos a la
distinción entre ellos
en un momento.
Volviendo al escenario, y trabajando bajo el
supuesto de que Alice y Bob comparten un e-bit, veremos
que Alice y Bob
tienen todo lo que necesitan
para llevar a cabo la tarea, y eso es lo que hace el protocolo de
teletransportación cuántica, concretamente usando dos bits
de comunicación clásica.
Antes de entrar en
estos detalles, sin embargo, déjame hacer algunos comentarios rápidos
para asegurarme de que los supuestos queden claros.
Primero, estamos asumiendo
aquí que el estado de Q es desconocido para Alice y
Bob, así que en particular,
Alice no puede enviarle a Bob una
descripción del estado Q porque en general ella no lo conoce.
También debemos considerar la posibilidad de que Q esté correlacionado con otros sistemas, incluyendo la posibilidad
de que esté entrelazado
con otros sistemas y que la
transmisión de este qubit a Bob deba preservar esas correlaciones.
Por último, mencioné
el teorema de no clonación cuando hablaba de
intentar comunicar qubits de forma clásica, pero
hay otra conexión aquí
con el teorema de no clonación, que es que si Bob
recibe la transmisión de este qubit Q de Alice,
entonces ella ya no debe tenerlo
porque Q no puede clonarse, y eso es algo a tener en cuenta
mientras consideramos el protocolo de teletransportación.
El protocolo de teletransportación
puede describirse de una manera bastante simple y directa con el diagrama de circuit cuántico como puedes ver aquí.
Está ligeramente estilizado en
el sentido de que muestra la separación entre la parte de Alice y la parte de Bob, pero por lo demás, es simplemente
un diagrama de circuit cuántico,
todo lo que está por encima de la línea punteada
representa las acciones de Alice y todo lo que está por debajo
representa las acciones de Bob.
El tiempo avanza de izquierda a derecha como siempre, y vemos que comenzamos
con estos dos qubits aquí en un estado Phi plus,
así que este es el e-bit
con el que Alice y Bob comienzan.
Podemos poner etiquetas en los qubits para dejar claro cuál es cuál,
así que este es el qubit A, y este es el qubit
B que forman el e-bit,
y este es el qubit Q que
Alice desea transmitir a Bob.
Aquí estamos suponiendo que
el estado de este qubit Q es Psi, pero un poco más adelante consideraremos la posibilidad
de que Q esté entrelazado
con algún otro sistema. Y lo que el diagrama afirma, porque hemos escrito psi aquí abajo,
es que este circuit
transmite efectivamente cualquier estado psi que tuviéramos
aquí en la parte de Alice hacia aquí en la parte de Bob,
la única comunicación
que cruza la
línea entre Alice y Bob son los dos bits
clásicos representados por estas líneas dobles aquí.
Reduzcamos este
diagrama un poco para tener algo más de espacio y examinemos el
circuit más de cerca.
Ya describí
las condiciones iniciales, pero solo para recapitular, Alice tiene el qubit A
y Bob tiene el qubit B,
donde A y B juntos
están en un estado Phi plus, que es lo que significa compartir un e-bit.
Alice también tiene este qubit Q que desea transmitir a Bob, y estamos considerando el caso en que Q está en algún estado cuántico arbitrario Psi.
Ahora bien, no sabemos nada
sobre cómo Alice y Bob llegaron a tener este e-bit.
Podría ser que lo hayan
tenido por mucho tiempo, quizás lo crearon hace algún tiempo cuando estaban en el mismo lugar
y lo han estado guardando
para esta ocasión, pero esos detalles no son relevantes aquí.
Los pasos que suceden a continuación, que representan el
protocolo de teletransportación en sí, son los siguientes, y para que quede claro,
estos son los pasos que
describe el diagrama y simplemente los vamos a
escribir en palabras para que quede claro lo que
el diagrama expresa.
Alice primero realiza una
operación NOT controlada donde el qubit Q que
quiere enviar a Bob es el control y el
qubit A es el objetivo.
El siguiente paso es que ella
realiza una operación Hadamard sobre Q, y luego mide
los dos qubits que tiene,
A y Q con respecto a
mediciones de la base estándar, y llamamos a minúscula al resultado de la medición del qubit A,
y llamamos b minúscula al resultado de la medición del qubit Q.
Alice entonces envía esos
dos bits clásicos a Bob, y esta es la única comunicación involucrada en este protocolo, lo cual está indicado en el diagrama
por el hecho de que estos dos
bits cruzan la línea punteada entre Alice y Bob,
que puedes pensar como representando la
distancia que los separa.
Después de que Bob recibe los bits
a y b, hace dos cosas.
Primero, si a es igual a uno, entonces realiza una operación X
o, en otras palabras, un NOT gate en su qubit B,
y en caso contrario, si a es igual a cero, entonces no hace eso.
Y de manera similar,
si b es igual a uno, entonces Bob realiza una operación Z
o un Z-gate o un phase flip
también en el qubit b y, como
antes, si b es igual a cero, entonces no hace eso.
Todo esto se indica en la figura donde tenemos estos controlled-X
y controlled-Z gates donde los controles son
los dos bits clásicos.
No tienes que pensar en estos gates como gates controlados
si no quieres, esta es solo una manera conveniente
de expresar lo que queremos
en forma de un diagrama de circuit. El punto es que Bob aplica
un X-gate al qubit b si a es igual a uno y
luego aplica un Z-gate
al qubit b si b es igual a uno.
Y para mayor comodidad más adelante, podemos escribir explícitamente
la operación combinada que Bob realiza en su qubit b,
dependiendo de los bits clásicos
que Alice envía.
Así que ese es el protocolo de teleportación, es bastante simple en realidad, el
hecho de que realmente funcione es otro asunto
y aunque el análisis
no es tan complicado,
no deberías sentir que te estás perdiendo algo si no ves de inmediato por qué funciona.
Por eso necesitamos
hacer un análisis y eso es lo que haremos a continuación.
Para analizar el protocolo de teleportación, lo trabajaremos paso a paso para ver cuáles son los estados
de los tres qubits en diferentes momentos.
Primero vamos a considerar
el caso en que el qubit superior está en el estado AlphaZero más beta uno, donde alpha y beta
son números complejos cualesquiera
que hacen que este vector
sea un vector unitario.
Este es el qubit Q que
Alice intenta transmitir, pero en este momento no nos importa realmente
cómo se llama.
Un poco más adelante,
veremos la situación en la que este qubit está
entrelazado con otro sistema, pero este es un buen punto de partida para mantener las cosas simples
y para ver cómo funciona el análisis
un poco más claramente.
Si consideramos el estado de
los tres qubits juntos aquí al inicio, vemos
que este estado tiene la forma que ves aquí mismo.
Los primeros dos qubits están
en el estado Phi plus, el tercer qubit es el de arriba
según la convención
para ordenar qubits que
describí en la lección anterior, y entonces tomamos el producto tensorial para obtener el estado de los
tres qubits juntos.
Podemos expandir esta expresión
sustituyendo primero la definición del estado Phi plus y luego calculando el producto tensorial
y obtenemos el estado
que ves aquí mismo.
No siempre es la mejor
estrategia, por cierto, expandir completamente
un vector como este, generalmente es buena idea esperar hasta que
tengas una buena razón para hacerlo.
Pero aquí sí tenemos una razón, que es que nos
gustaría calcular la acción de este controlled NOT gate y al escribir el estado en esta forma,
podemos hacer eso muy fácilmente.
Y en particular, este es
el estado de los tres qubits después de que se aplica el controlled NOT gate.
El tercer qubit es el qubit de control porque ese es el que está
arriba según nuestra convención, y el segundo qubit,
que es el del medio,
es el objetivo, así que simplemente
operamos sobre los kets según corresponda, si el tercer bit es
cero, no ocurre nada,
y si el tercer bit es uno,
entonces invertimos el segundo bit.
Luego realizamos el Hadamard
gate en el tercer qubit, podemos escribir el vector resultante
como puedes ver
aquí mismo, sustituyendo el
estado plus y el estado minus por el estado cero y el estado uno.
Y si queremos tener suficiente
espacio para expandir este, vamos a necesitar reducirlo
un poco y ahora, sustituyendo los estados
plus y minus
con sus definiciones,
llevando la raíz cuadrada de dos al denominador, obtenemos el estado que ves aquí mismo.
Y al expandir ese, obtenemos el estado que ves aquí mismo.
Entonces, ese es el estado de los tres qubits después de que Alice realiza sus dos operaciones.
Alice entonces mide
y si queremos analizar las mediciones, lo que hacemos es aislar los vectores de la base estándar
para los sistemas que se miden
tal como hablamos en la lección dos, y si hacemos eso en este caso particular, esto es lo que obtenemos.
Y si miras esa
expresión por un momento, puede parecer un poco peculiar porque ahora parece que el primer qubit,
que es el qubit inferior,
de alguna manera depende de alpha y beta, aunque en
este punto no ha habido ninguna comunicación a través de la línea punteada,
pero eso es solo una ilusión. Recuerda que los escalares pasan
libremente a través de los productos tensoriales, así que realmente no tiene sentido
decir que alpha y beta
están asociados con el primer qubit.
Todo lo que hemos hecho
aquí es usar paréntesis de acuerdo con la
multilinealidad de los productos tensoriales.
De todas formas, esa es la forma que necesitamos para ver qué hace la medición, y podemos ver una
cosa interesante de inmediato
y es que las probabilidades de los cuatro posibles resultados de medición siempre son uniformes.
La probabilidad de medir cada
par de resultados de medición es un cuarto, así que, en particular,
no hay ninguna dependencia
en absoluto de alpha y beta.
Podemos verlo en cada caso calculando la norma euclídea al cuadrado del
vector que está tensoreado con el vector de la base estándar
que aislamos,
y en cada caso tenemos un cuarto, que obtenemos elevando al cuadrado un medio multiplicado por el valor absoluto al cuadrado de alpha
más el valor absoluto
al cuadrado de beta, que es uno, y así obtenemos un cuarto en cada caso.
Es bastante importante
de hecho que las probabilidades de estos distintos resultados no dependan de ninguna manera del qubit que
Alice quiere transmitir.
No podríamos tener que un estado arbitrario entre por aquí arriba y salga por aquí abajo y que, aun así, una medición revele
información sobre ese estado.
Si quieres obtener información sobre un estado cuántico arbitrario, vas a tener que perturbar
ese estado en general.
Aquí hay una tabla que describe no solo las probabilidades
de los distintos resultados, sino también el estado de
los tres qubits juntos
condicionado a cada posible
resultado de medición.
Obtenemos esto normalizando los vectores tensoreados con los distintos
estados de la base estándar, pero eso es fácil en este caso,
simplemente eliminamos el factor de un medio para obtener un vector unitario.
Entonces, lo que tenemos inmediatamente
después de que Alice mide es que Alice tiene dos bits
aleatorios uniformes y eso es todo.
En particular, ya no
tiene el estado original y no tiene ninguna
información sobre él, solo tiene bits aleatorios.
El estado de Bob ahora sí
depende de alpha y beta, así como de los resultados de la medición.
Si imaginamos momentáneamente
que Alice todavía no ha enviado los resultados de la medición
de modo que Bob no sabe cuáles son,
entonces no podría
obtener ninguna información sobre alpha y beta
midiendo su qubit.
Estas cuatro posibilidades
que tenemos aquí están suficientemente mezcladas para garantizar que ninguna información
sobre alpha y beta
pueda obtenerse jamás
mediante una medición. Eso tiene que ser cierto a un nivel intuitivo porque, de lo contrario, tendríamos
comunicación más rápida que la luz.
Alice definitivamente no puede
transmitir información a Bob sin enviar nada en absoluto, pero por supuesto Alice sí
envía los resultados de la medición
a Bob, así que ampliemos la tabla para ver qué ocurre cuando
Bob realiza sus operaciones.
En esta columna de aquí, tenemos las distintas operaciones que Bob realiza efectivamente para cada uno de los posibles
resultados de las mediciones
como observamos antes,
y si vamos uno por uno y aplicamos esa
operación al qubit de Bob, que es el primero, B,
vemos que obtenemos el mismo
resultado en los cuatro casos y ese resultado es el estado original.
Así que el estado original del qubit Q se ha teletransportado correctamente a B.
Si Bob quiere renombrar su qubit y llamarlo Q en este punto, desde luego puede hacerlo, pero la cuestión es que ahora
él tiene el estado original
que tenía Alice y, por supuesto, inevitablemente, Alice ya no lo tiene.
Observa también que el e-bit
se ha consumido efectivamente durante este proceso,
la teletransportación tiene un coste
y el coste es un e-bit y dos bits clásicos de comunicación, y cuando el protocolo
termina, el e-bit desaparece.
Hemos demostrado ahora que
el protocolo de teletransportación funciona correctamente bajo el supuesto de que el qubit superior está en un estado cuántico
de la forma alpha por el ket
cero más beta por el ket uno.
Pero ¿qué ocurre si el
qubit superior está entrelazado con algún otro sistema, como
uno de nuestros qubits adicionales
como tenemos aquí en la pantalla? Puede que queramos usar la teletransportación
en tales circunstancias.
Quizás Alice y Bob realmente
planean realizar la teletransportación 100 veces para que Alice pueda transmitir
un registro cuántico de 100 qubits
a Bob, un qubit a la vez.
O quizás estos qubits adicionales
ni siquiera están en posesión de Alice
y los tiene alguien más, puede que Alice ni siquiera
sepa que existen.
La pregunta es: ¿sigue
funcionando la teletransportación aunque el qubit que se teletransporta esté entrelazado con otro sistema?
Aquí, el estado del qubit Q junto con el sistema adicional
que estamos considerando se expresa como puedes ver justo aquí arriba
donde gamma cero y
gamma uno son vectores unitarios que representan estados cuánticos
de este sistema adicional.
Siempre podemos escribir un estado arbitrario del sistema combinado de esta forma.
En realidad ni siquiera
necesitamos alpha y beta aquí, pero si los incluimos,
entonces podemos tomar gamma cero y gamma uno como vectores unitarios
y eso hará que la
conexión con el caso más simple que ya hemos considerado sea más transparente.
Podemos hacer un
análisis similar al que ya hicimos, pero donde también llevamos un seguimiento
de este sistema adicional.
Es un poco más complicado porque tenemos el sistema adicional, pero
la idea es exactamente la misma; aquí hay un resumen muy breve.
Este es el estado inicial, aquí está el estado después
de la compuerta NOT controlada,
y aquí está el estado después
de la operación Hadamard.
Si expandimos estas cosas,
podemos expresar ese estado como puedes ver aquí,
ese es el estado justo antes
de las mediciones de Alice, y si repasamos las
posibilidades como antes,
y consideramos qué
ocurre cuando Bob aplica la operación que se supone que debe aplicar,
entonces encontramos que efectivamente
el estado correcto resulta y el protocolo funciona como se esperaba.
En esta tabla, por cierto, usamos la letra R para
referirnos a este sistema adicional, y puedes ver que usamos
un truco bastante sencillo,
que consiste en decidir que preferiríamos, al menos momentáneamente, ordenar
los sistemas como B, R, A, Q
porque es más conveniente para escribir los estados aquí.
Según el diagrama, los sistemas deberían
estar ordenados como B, A, Q, R,
pero siempre que lo dejemos claro, podemos elegir un orden
diferente que sea más conveniente.
En pocas palabras, todo lo que ocurre en este análisis es lo
mismo que lo que ocurrió en el análisis más simple,
pero resulta que tenemos
estos vectores adicionales, gamma cero y gamma uno,
que básicamente van de pasajeros.
Siempre tenemos gamma cero
cuando hay un factor de alfa y gamma uno cuando
hay un factor de beta, y al final del día
todo funciona correctamente.
Esto en realidad no sorprende en absoluto, tenemos un proceso físico que actúa como la operación
identidad sobre un qubit
en un estado cuántico arbitrario, y solo hay una
manera en que eso puede ocurrir, y es que la operación
sea la operación identidad.
Eso es un poco más fácil de explicar usando la formulación general
de la información cuántica, pero el punto es que por linealidad,
realmente no necesitábamos pasar por este análisis adicional.
Una vez que sabemos que
la teletransportación funciona correctamente para un solo qubit de forma aislada, podemos concluir que solo hay
una cosa posible
que puede describir lo que hace el protocolo, y es que implementa
la operación identidad donde un qubit entra aquí
y sale aquí, actuando efectivamente como un canal cuántico perfecto
sin ruido.
Solo unas pocas observaciones rápidas
sobre la teletransportación antes de pasar al
segundo ejemplo de la lección, que es la codificación superdensa.
Primero, creo que es importante aclarar que la teletransportación no es una aplicación de la información cuántica, es un protocolo
y específicamente es un
protocolo para realizar comunicación cuántica.
Para que la teletransportación
tal como la he descrito sea útil, tiene que haber alguna razón para realizar comunicación cuántica.
Segundo, es razonable especular que la teletransportación podría, algún
día, convertirse en una forma estándar
de comunicar información cuántica, y específicamente un proceso conocido como destilación de entrelazamiento
podría usarse potencialmente
como una forma de comunicar qubits de manera confiable. Si Alice y Bob saben que van
a comunicar información cuántica o tienen la necesidad de comunicar
información cuántica, entonces este proceso de destilación de entrelazamiento
podría usarse para convertir un mayor número de e-bits ruidosos
en un menor número
de e-bits de alta calidad que podrían usarse para teletransportación sin ruido o casi sin ruido.
La idea es que el proceso
de destilación de entrelazamiento no es tan delicado en cierto sentido, podríamos aceptar pérdidas y
si no funciona,
simplemente podríamos intentarlo de nuevo, mientras que los qubits reales que
nos gustaría comunicar podrían considerarse mucho más valiosos.
Por supuesto, todo esto es especulación, pero el punto es que no es difícil imaginar situaciones
en las que la teletransportación
podría ser una forma muy práctica
de comunicar qubits.
Y el punto final
sobre la teletransportación es que la idea detrás de la teletransportación y la manera en que funciona
es bastante fundamental
en la información y computación cuántica, la teletransportación es realmente una piedra angular de la teoría
de información cuántica, y las variaciones
sobre la idea también aparecen con frecuencia,
es solo un ejemplo, hay propuestas para
implementar diferentes quantum gates
usando teletransportación, pero
donde se eligen diferentes estados iniciales y mediciones de modo que el resultado
sea aplicar una operación elegida
en lugar de comunicar.
El siguiente ejemplo es la codificación superdensa.
Al igual que la teletransportación cuántica,
la codificación superdensa es un protocolo y lo que logra es complementario a la teletransportación.
Mientras que la teletransportación permite
transmitir un qubit usando un e-bit y dos
bits clásicos de comunicación,
la codificación superdensa permite
transmitir dos bits clásicos usando
un e-bit y un qubit de comunicación cuántica.
Entonces, en pocas palabras, la codificación superdensa permite la transmisión
de información clásica y la razón por la que se
llama codificación superdensa
es que permite empaquetar dos
bits clásicos de comunicación en un solo qubit,
pero tenemos que consumir un
e-bit para lograrlo.
Aquí hay una explicación más precisa
de la configuración.
Una vez más, tenemos a Alice y Bob, donde Alice es la emisora
y Bob es el receptor, y esta vez Alice tiene dos bits clásicos
que quiere enviarle a Bob.
Alice puede enviarle a Bob un solo qubit y Alice y Bob comparten
un e-bit que pueden usar para ayudarse a completar su tarea,
que es que Bob reciba
los dos bits clásicos.
Ahora bien, en cierto sentido esta tarea puede parecer menos interesante que la que
logra la teletransportación,
especialmente si consideramos
que enviar qubits es significativamente más
difícil o más complejo que enviar bits clásicos,
lo cual es un punto de vista bastante razonable, pero definitivamente es interesante que sea posible hacer esto.
Una razón por la que es interesante
es que en realidad es imposible lograr
esta tarea de transmitir dos bits clásicos de información
usando un solo qubit sin
hacer uso del e-bit.
Sabemos esto gracias a un famoso teorema conocido como el teorema de Holevo.
El teorema de Holevo es
más general que esto, y el enunciado preciso
del teorema de Holevo es un poco técnico y
requiere algo de explicación,
pero una de sus implicaciones
es que no puedes transmitir ninguna cantidad de bits clásicos
de comunicación usando menos qubits de
comunicación cuántica por sí solos.
Si quieres transmitir de forma fiable dos bits clásicos de
información usando qubits y no tienes un
e-bit disponible,
tendrás que enviar dos qubits, así que bien podrían almacenar directamente los bits que quieres transmitir.
Otra razón por la que la codificación
superdensa es interesante es por la estrecha
relación complementaria que tiene con la teletransportación, y
volveremos a esto
un poco más adelante. Aquí tienes una descripción en circuit cuántico del protocolo de codificación superdensa.
Para este,
no voy a enumerar todos los pasos, sino que nos quedaremos con la descripción del diagrama de circuit.
Como puedes ver, tenemos de nuevo
a Alice y Bob, donde Alice está arriba
y Bob está abajo.
Aquí está el e-bit que
comparten inicialmente Alice y Bob, que se
ha establecido de algún modo antes de ejecutar el protocolo.
Alice tiene dos bits clásicos, A y B, que puedes ver aquí arriba,
y a través del protocolo que describe el circuit,
estos dos bits clásicos
terminarán en manos de Bob.
Solo hay un qubit
que cruza la línea entre Alice y Bob, y por supuesto no se está
enviando ningún bit clásico,
la transmisión de
los dos bits clásicos es el objetivo del protocolo.
También notarás que tiene
exactamente los mismos componentes que se usan en la teletransportación: tenemos una gate NOT controlada, una gate Hadamard,
y una gate Z y una gate X
controladas por bits clásicos.
Sin embargo, están dispuestas de forma diferente, así que pasemos al
análisis para ver cómo funciona.
Para analizar cómo funciona la codificación superdensa, empecemos escribiendo
la base de Bell, que está muy en el
centro del análisis.
Lo que vamos a hacer es
primero observar el efecto que tienen las acciones de Alice
sobre el estado Phi plus, y lo que veremos es
que Alice transforma este
estado Phi plus en uno
de los cuatro estados de Bell dependiendo de los bits
que quiere enviar.
Así que, escribamos una tabla para poder
llevar el control de lo que está pasando.
Primero, si A y B son ambos cero, entonces no se aplica ni la gate Z ni
la gate X, así que las acciones de Alice no hacen nada,
lo que significa que Phi
plus se mapea a Phi plus.
También podemos expresar eso como una ecuación como la que ves aquí,
no ocurre nada en el qubit de Alice y no ocurre nada en el qubit de Bob,
y no hacer nada está representado
por la matriz identidad.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa si A es igual a cero y B es igual a uno?
Pues bien, como B es igual a uno, aplicamos la gate Z y
no aplicamos la gate X porque A es igual a cero,
y vemos que el efecto global es que Alice realiza una gate Z.
Alice está a la derecha
porque está arriba, aunque en realidad no
haría ninguna diferencia en este caso
concreto; el efecto es que
el estado Phi plus
se transforma en Phi minus, lo que puedes comprobar a simple vista
a partir de estas expresiones si recuerdas cómo funciona la gate Z.
Así que, podemos añadir este a nuestra tabla; quedan otros dos casos, si A es igual a uno
y B es igual a cero,
entonces Alice realiza una
gate X que transforma Phi plus en Chi plus, y si A es igual a uno
y B es igual a uno,
entonces Alice realiza Z, luego
X y obtenemos Chi minus.
Así que, nuestra tabla nos dice qué ocurre en los cuatro casos posibles, y es que Alice elige efectivamente cuál
de los cuatro estados de Bell
quiere compartir con Bob, y tiene la libertad de elegir actuando solo sobre su qubit,
y ese es un aspecto bastante interesante
del entrelazamiento.
Luego Alice le envía su qubit
a Bob; en este punto, Bob tiene uno de los cuatro estados de Bell y solo necesita
averiguar cuál es
para recuperar los bits.
Y podemos comprobar que
efectivamente un gate NOT controlado seguido de un gate Hadamard
tal como aparece en el diagrama hace lo correcto.
No voy a repasarlos en detalle, pero si decides hacerlo, verás que el efecto es
el que aparece aquí en la tabla.
Una manera de comprobarlo
es simplemente calcularlo. Alternativamente, podemos reconocer que en realidad ya
hicimos esto en orden inverso
en la lección anterior. En la lección anterior
teníamos primero el gate Hadamard y luego el gate NOT controlado
y vimos que ese circuit
mapeaba los estados de la base estándar a los estados de Bell con un incómodo
signo menos en uno de los casos.
Cuando invertimos el orden de los gates y tenemos en cuenta
que estos dos gates son sus propios inversos,
lo que obtenemos es el inverso,
y entonces lo que tenemos en este
caso es que la acción va en dirección opuesta
y el signo menos puede aparecer en el lado
que quiera,
pero en lo demás, está donde le corresponde, y en este punto queda
inmediato que la medición revela los valores correctos,
el signo menos aquí no nos molesta porque uno aparece con
probabilidad uno en este caso, y eso es todo el análisis.
En pocas palabras, Alice elige un estado de Bell y Bob descubre cuál es.
Solo un par de breves observaciones
sobre la codificación superdensa antes de continuar; primero, debemos reconocer
que la codificación superdensa
probablemente no sea
útil ni práctica en ningún sentido como medio para
transmitir información clásica.
La comunicación clásica
es muy económica y enviar qubits físicamente es todo un desafío, por decir lo menos,
y mientras eso siga siendo así, no esperaríamos ninguna
ventaja práctica en absoluto de la codificación superdensa.
Pero el hecho de que probablemente
no sea práctica no significa que la codificación superdensa
no sea interesante.
De hecho es muy interesante: la idea subyacente
es realmente bastante fundamental,
y cuando me refiero a la idea subyacente, me refiero a la idea de que si Alice
comparte un estado de Bell con Bob,
entonces ella puede cambiar ese estado a cualquier otro estado de Bell
que ella elija por sí sola, no necesita la ayuda de Bob
en absoluto para hacer eso.
Este es un ejemplo específico
que concierne a los estados de Bell, pero hay una idea subyacente más general que concierne a la libertad que un jugador
tiene para transformar un estado entrelazado que comparte con otro jugador, y entender exactamente
qué es esa libertad
es un paso importante para comprender la información cuántica, y veremos exactamente cómo describir esa libertad en términos simples
y elegantes en la
tercera unidad de la serie.
La codificación superdensa también
ofrece un ejemplo concreto de lo que se puede hacer con el entrelazamiento, que es permitir que dos bits clásicos sean transmitidos
enviando un único qubit. Como ya mencioné, esto
es demostrablemente imposible por el teorema de Holevo sin entrelazamiento.
También podemos considerar la teleportación y la codificación superdensa juntas, y vemos que
establecen una equivalencia
entre un qubit de comunicación cuántica y dos bits de comunicación clásica.
Mientras estés dispuesto
a gastar un e-bit, puedes convertir efectivamente
uno en el otro.
La teleportación permite la
comunicación de un qubit usando dos bits clásicos de comunicación y la codificación superdensa va en la otra dirección
y permite dos bits clásicos
de comunicación usando un qubit de comunicación cuántica.
Sin gastar el e-bit, sin embargo, no puedes transformar
ninguno en el otro; es el entrelazamiento el que
hace esto posible.
El tercero y último ejemplo
que veremos en esta lección no es un protocolo sino un
juego conocido como el juego CHSH.
Cuando hablamos de un juego en este contexto, no estamos hablando de algo pensado para
jugarlo por diversión o por deporte,
sino más bien de una abstracción matemática en el sentido de la teoría de juegos, por ejemplo.
Las abstracciones matemáticas de juegos se estudian muy comúnmente en
economía e informática, por ejemplo, y hay
bastante valor
en la abstracción, así que los juegos no son todo diversión
en los juegos, como resulta,
aunque sí es divertido pensar en ellos.
En este caso particular, lo que tenemos es esencialmente
un experimento mental que se puede describir de una
manera bastante intuitiva como un juego.
Las letras CHSH hacen referencia a los autores, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony y Richard Holt, de un artículo de 1969
donde el ejemplo
fue descrito por primera vez. En realidad no lo describieron
como un juego, y es bastante común
referirse a este ejemplo
no como el juego CHSH, sino
como la desigualdad CHSH.
Para un informático como yo, sin embargo, es muy natural
describirlo como un juego.
Ya he sugerido que
las abstracciones matemáticas de juegos son importantes y útiles, y hay muchas
categorías distintas de juegos
que se pueden considerar. El juego CHSH es un
ejemplo de una clase de juegos llamados juegos no locales.
Esta es la configuración general
de un juego no local.
Tenemos dos jugadores, Alice y Bob, que cooperan como equipo, así que ganan juntos
o pierden juntos.
Esto significa que no tienen
incentivo para actuar de manera egoísta, así que es esencialmente el extremo opuesto
a los juegos de suma cero,
que son puramente competitivos; aquí el juego es puramente cooperativo.
Hay una tercera entidad llamada el árbitro.
El árbitro no es un jugador en el juego, sino que el árbitro
dirige el juego, y de hecho, puedes pensar en la especificación
de una instancia particular
de un juego no local y la especificación de un
árbitro como si fueran equivalentes.
Hay una restricción de vital importancia que se impone a Alice y Bob, que es que una vez que comienza el juego, se les prohíbe
comunicarse entre sí.
Pueden ponerse de acuerdo de antemano en
la estrategia que elijan, pero no se permite
ninguna comunicación entre ellos durante el juego en sí.
Si quieres, puedes imaginarte
que el juego tiene lugar en algún tipo de instalación segura, como si el árbitro estuviera haciendo
el papel de un detective
y Alice y Bob son sospechosos ubicados en diferentes
habitaciones en una comisaría, pero otra forma de
pensar en la configuración
es que Alice y Bob están
separados por una enorme distancia y la comunicación está prohibida porque la velocidad de la luz
no permite la comunicación
lo suficientemente rápido. Si Alice intenta enviar un
mensaje a Bob, por ejemplo, el juego habrá terminado para
cuando Bob lo reciba.
La forma en que funciona un juego no local
es que primero, el árbitro le hace una pregunta tanto a
Alice como a Bob.
La pregunta de Alice se etiqueta como X y la pregunta de Bob se etiqueta como Y.
En general, puedes pensar en X e Y como estados clásicos
de cualesquiera estados clásicos que quieras y en el
caso específico del juego CHSH,
X e Y son bits.
Alice y Bob deben entonces dar respuestas, la respuesta de Alice se etiqueta como A
y la respuesta de Bob se etiqueta como B,
y de nuevo, estas respuestas se pueden ver como estados clásicos en general y, al igual que las preguntas, serán
bits en el juego CHSH.
En este punto, el
árbitro toma una decisión, Alice y Bob ganan o pierden dependiendo de si la
pareja de respuestas A, B
se considera correcta para la
pareja de preguntas X, Y que hizo el árbitro, y voy a decir algo más
al respecto en un momento.
Primero, echemos un vistazo más de cerca al árbitro para entender qué es
lo que resulta potencialmente desafiante para Alice y Bob en un juego no local.
Y lo que hace que un juego no local
sea potencialmente desafiante es que el árbitro puede usar aleatoriedad para elegir las preguntas X e Y.
Eso significa que Alice
y Bob tienen incertidumbre, no saben de antemano qué pregunta les van a hacer, y quizás más importante aún,
no saben qué pregunta
recibió el otro y es esa incertidumbre
junto con el hecho de que no pueden comunicarse
lo que presenta el desafío.
Así que es similar a la situación en la que un detective
interroga a dos sospechosos en habitaciones diferentes, si
los sospechosos no saben
qué preguntas le hacen al otro, es mucho más difícil si son culpables mantener coherente su versión de los hechos.
Ahora bien, mencioné hace un momento que el árbitro toma una determinación
sobre si Alice y Bob han respondido
correctamente o incorrectamente
según las preguntas
que se les hicieron.
Se asume que esta
determinación se hace de acuerdo con alguna regla fija
y puedes considerar cualquier regla que quieras,
pero sea cual sea,
se asume que Alice
y Bob conocen la regla, así que al menos tienen una
oportunidad de responder correctamente.
Vamos a echar un vistazo a la
regla del juego CHSH en un momento, pero podríamos
considerar una regla diferente y tendríamos un ejemplo diferente
de un juego no local.
Algunos juegos no locales son interesantes y de hecho algunos son bastante fascinantes y misteriosos hasta el día de hoy, y
algunos no son tan interesantes,
esa es simplemente la naturaleza del
modelo de juegos no locales.
En cualquier caso, estas son las dos cosas diferentes que se necesitan para describir un árbitro; cómo se eligen exactamente las preguntas
y qué pares de respuestas son correctos para cada posible par de preguntas.
Si tenemos una descripción
de esas dos cosas, entonces tenemos una descripción del árbitro y eso describe de manera efectiva
una instancia de un juego no local.
Ahora echemos un vistazo al
juego CHSH específicamente.
La forma en que se define el juego
o, de manera equivalente, cómo se define el árbitro es la siguiente:
primero, como ya he mencionado, las preguntas y respuestas son todas bits, así que el árbitro le envía un bit X
a Alice y un bit Y a Bob,
y cada uno responde con un bit. Alice responde con A
y Bob responde con B.
La forma en que el árbitro elige
qué preguntas hacer es simple, las elige
de manera uniformemente aleatoria,
así que la pareja de preguntas X, Y tiene la misma probabilidad de ser cualquiera
de las cuatro posibilidades: cero, cero; cero, uno;
uno, cero; y uno, uno.
Por último, la regla que
determina qué respuestas ganan y qué respuestas pierden es
que una pareja de respuestas A, B es correcta para la pareja de preguntas X, Y
si y solo si la o-exclusiva de A y B es igual a la y lógica de X e Y.
Puede ser un poco más fácil de asimilar si expresamos esas condiciones
en forma de tabla como ves aquí.
En la primera columna, tenemos las cuatro posibles parejas de preguntas, y en la segunda columna tenemos
las condiciones sobre A y B
que se requieren para que
Alice y Bob ganen.
En los primeros tres casos,
la y de A e Y es cero, por lo que la o-exclusiva debe ser igual a cero
para que puedan ganar,
y eso es lo mismo que decir que A y B deben ser iguales, porque A y B son bits,
y en el cuarto caso,
la Y lógica de X e Y es igual
a uno, por lo que la O exclusiva de A y B debe ser igual a uno para que Alice y Bob ganen
y eso es lo mismo
que decir que A y B deben ser diferentes.
Entonces, ese es el juego CHSH, y ahora podemos pensar en
distintas estrategias posibles para Alice y Bob, y qué tan
bien pueden jugar.
Empecemos pensando en
estrategias deterministas, donde la respuesta A de Alice es una
función de la pregunta X que recibe, y
del mismo modo, la respuesta B de Bob
es una función de la
pregunta Y que él recibe.
Y resulta que ninguna
estrategia determinista puede ganar siempre.
Una forma de razonar esto es
simplemente repasar una por una todas las estrategias
deterministas posibles y comprobar que cada una de ellas pierde
en al menos uno de los cuatro
posibles pares de preguntas.
Alice y Bob tienen cada uno
cuatro funciones posibles entre las que elegir; vimos esas
cuatro funciones en la lección uno, así que hay 16 posibilidades
que comprobar en total.
Otra forma de verlo es
pensar en las ecuaciones que aparecen en la pantalla; estamos pensando
en estrategias deterministas
donde A y B son funciones
de X e Y respectivamente.
Así, por ejemplo, A de cero
representa la respuesta de Alice cuando su pregunta X es igual a cero, y A de uno representa la respuesta de Alice
cuando su pregunta X es igual a uno.
Estas son las cuatro ecuaciones
que deben ser verdaderas para que se cumplan las
condiciones de victoria en cada uno de los cuatro casos.
Por ejemplo, si X es igual a
cero e Y es igual a cero, entonces la O exclusiva de A
y B debe ser igual a cero,
mientras que en el caso en que X es igual a uno e Y es igual a uno, la
O exclusiva de A y B debe ser igual a uno.
Una forma de ver que
no hay manera de elegir las funciones A y B de modo que
todas estas ecuaciones sean verdaderas, es simplemente calcular la O exclusiva
de todas las ecuaciones.
La O exclusiva de cualquier
valor binario consigo mismo es igual a cero, y por tanto se concluye que la O exclusiva
de los lados izquierdos
es igual a cero; eso se debe a
que tenemos dos instancias de A cero, dos instancias de A uno,
dos instancias de B cero
y dos instancias de B uno.
Así que, si hacemos la O exclusiva de todos,
obtenemos un resultado final de cero, pero si tomamos la O exclusiva de los lados derechos de las ecuaciones,
obtenemos uno, no cero. Por lo tanto, las cuatro ecuaciones
no pueden ser todas verdaderas a la vez; al menos una de ellas tiene que ser falsa
y eso llevará a una
derrota para Alice y Bob en al menos uno de los cuatro casos.
Y así se concluye que, dado que el árbitro elige las preguntas
de forma uniforme, la probabilidad de que Alice y Bob ganen
usando una estrategia determinista
es como máximo tres cuartos, o el 75%.
El hecho de que Alice y Bob puedan ganar con probabilidad tres cuartos es bastante fácil de ver
en realidad; si Alice y Bob responden siempre cero
todo el tiempo, por ejemplo,
acertarán tres
de las cuatro veces.
Así que Alice y Bob no pueden
hacerlo mejor que ganar el 75% de las veces usando una
estrategia determinista.
¿Pero qué pasa con una estrategia probabilista?
Pues resulta que usar
una estrategia probabilista no les ayuda en absoluto, porque toda
estrategia probabilista
puede verse alternativamente
como una selección aleatoria de una estrategia determinista, igual que las
operaciones probabilistas pueden verse
como selecciones aleatorias de
operaciones deterministas, como vimos en la primera lección.
El promedio nunca
es mayor que el máximo, por lo que se concluye que una
estrategia probabilista no ofrece ninguna ventaja
en términos de ganar
sobre una estrategia determinista. Esto incluye incluso la posibilidad de que las elecciones aleatorias de Alice y Bob estén correlacionadas.
Entonces, la conclusión es que ganar con probabilidad tres cuartos es lo mejor que Alice
y Bob pueden lograr usando cualquier estrategia clásica,
ya sea determinista
o probabilista.
La pregunta natural que surge en este punto es si Alice y Bob pueden hacerlo mejor usando una estrategia cuántica,
y en particular
si comparten un estado cuántico entrelazado que podrían haber preparado
antes de jugar el juego, ¿eso puede ayudarles?
La respuesta es sí, puede, y ese es el punto central del ejemplo, y por eso es tan interesante.
Veamos exactamente cómo
Alice y Bob pueden hacerlo mejor en este juego usando el entrelazamiento.
Lo primero que necesitamos hacer es definir un vector de estado cuántico Chi
theta para cada ángulo theta, como puedes ver aquí en la pantalla.
Así, Chi theta es igual a
coseno de theta por el ket cero más seno de theta por el ket
uno, y aquí, por cierto,
estamos pensando en
ángulos en términos de radianes.
Por ejemplo, aquí está el vector que obtenemos cuando theta es igual a pi sobre
cuatro, que son 45 grados.
El coseno de pi sobre cuatro
y el seno de pi sobre cuatro son ambos iguales a uno sobre
la raíz cuadrada de dos, así que esto es simplemente otro
nombre para el estado más.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo cuando theta es igual a tres veces pi sobre ocho, y en caso de que no
recuerdes el seno
y el coseno de tres veces pi sobre ocho de memoria,
aquí hay una tabla de los senos y los cosenos que vamos
a necesitar
a lo largo de este ejemplo
e incluye los que necesitamos para este vector en particular.
Ahora, si queremos calcular el producto interno entre dos de estos vectores
para ángulos alpha y beta, digamos, es
sencillo hacerlo.
Solo tenemos entradas de números reales
en estos vectores, así que no hay
conjugados complejos de qué preocuparnos, y obtenemos el producto de los cosenos
más el producto de los senos, y podemos usar una de las
llamadas fórmulas de adición de ángulos
para simplificar eso; es el
coseno de la diferencia entre los ángulos, y
como la función coseno
es simétrica alrededor de cero,
en realidad no importa en qué orden los tomemos.
Si no tienes este tipo
de identidades trigonométricas memorizadas,
por cierto, no eres el único, pero no tienes que recordarlas,
puedes simplemente buscarlas. Esta en particular sí tiene sentido
cuando piensas en la interpretación geométrica
del producto interno
entre vectores unitarios reales como el coseno del ángulo entre ellos.
Si calculamos el producto interno
del producto tensorial de dos de estos vectores
con el estado Phi plus, obtenemos una expresión similar
excepto que hay una raíz
de dos en el denominador.
Esta es la primera vez
que el estado Phi plus aparece en el contexto
de este ejemplo, por cierto, y veremos exactamente por qué nos interesa
este producto interno en particular en breve, pero por ahora
simplemente observemos que obtenemos la misma expresión que teníamos
para el producto interno dividido
por la raíz cuadrada de dos, así que podemos simplificar como antes.
A continuación, definiremos una
matriz unitaria, U theta, para cada ángulo theta
como ves aquí,
no es difícil
verificar que esta es efectivamente una matriz unitaria.
Lo clave que necesitamos
reconocer es que el vector si theta es ortogonal al
vector si theta más pi sobre dos, y eso tiene sentido
porque si rotamos por pi sobre dos, que son 90 grados, obtenemos
un vector ortogonal.
Si luego multiplicamos U theta
por U theta dagger, obtenemos la matriz identidad.
Intuitivamente hablando,
lo que esta matriz hace como operación es
mapear si theta a cat cero y si theta más pi dos a cat uno.
En este punto, tenemos
todo lo que necesitamos para describir la estrategia de Alice y Bob.
Primero, al igual que en la teletransportación y la codificación superdensa, Alice y Bob comenzarán compartiendo un e-bit.
Alice tiene el qubit A,
Bob tiene el qubit B, y juntos los dos qubits
están en el estado Phi plus.
Las acciones de Alice son las siguientes: mira el bit X que
recibe del árbitro,
y si X es igual a cero,
aplica U cero sobre A, que resulta ser lo
mismo que no hacer nada porque U cero es la matriz identidad,
si X es igual a uno, en cambio, aplica U pi sobre cuatro a A.
Después de aplicar una
de las dos operaciones, mide A usando una
medición en la base estándar y envía el resultado
que obtiene al árbitro.
Bob hace algo muy similar, su qubit se llama B, por supuesto, y recibe Y del
árbitro en lugar de X.
Pero la diferencia clave es
que usa diferentes ángulos para sus operaciones unitarias.
Si Y es igual a cero, aplica
U pi sobre ocho, y si Y es igual a uno, aplica U menos pi sobre ocho.
Y veremos por qué estas elecciones de ángulos son buenas elecciones en breve;
no es para nada obvio.
Y aquí hay un diagrama de circuit
que expresa esta estrategia.
Bob está arriba y Alice
está abajo esta vez; aquí está el e-bit que está entrando
y estos son los
gates unitarios que Alice y Bob podrían o no aplicar
dependiendo de lo que sean X e Y.
Para este y este, tenemos gates que están siendo controlados ya sea por el bit X o por el bit Y.
Y para estos dos de aquí, tenemos lo que parecen
gates de control excepto que el círculo no está relleno.
Y lo que esto significa es
que si el bit de control está en cero, entonces el gate se ejecuta, y si el control está en
uno, entonces no ocurre nada.
Así que es como un
gate de control ordinario excepto que los roles de cero y uno para el control están intercambiados.
Entonces, efectivamente, Bob
ejecuta este gate de aquí si Y es igual a cero, y
ejecuta este gate de aquí
si Y es igual a uno, y similarmente, Alice ejecuta este gate de
aquí si X es igual a cero, y este gate de aquí,
si X es igual a uno.
Entonces, esa es la estrategia de Alice y Bob, y ahora solo necesitamos
averiguar qué tan bien funciona.
Para el análisis de la estrategia cuántica que acabo de describir,
en realidad solo necesitamos dos cosas en este punto: primero, la
matriz unitaria U Theta
es como la ves aquí, y
segundo, teníamos esta fórmula.
En realidad ni siquiera necesitamos la definición del vector si theta más, estas dos ecuaciones son todo lo que necesitamos.
Hay cuatro casos a
considerar, comenzando con el caso uno, que es que X igual
a cero e Y igual a cero.
Y si miramos la estrategia, encontraremos que en este
caso Alice realiza U cero en su qubit y Bob realiza
U pi sobre ocho en su qubit.
Recuerda, Alice está
abajo y Bob está arriba, así que el estado que
obtienen se ve así.
Y al expandir eso
según la definición de U theta, obtenemos esta
expresión que ves aquí.
No necesitamos expandir
eso más porque tenemos la otra
fórmula para ayudarnos.
Y si aplicamos esa fórmula
para cada uno de los cuatro términos, lo que obtenemos es esto.
En este punto Alice y Bob miden y aquí hay una tabla que
explica la distribución de los resultados.
Tomamos el valor absoluto
al cuadrado de los coeficientes para obtener las probabilidades, que resultan ser los
cuadrados de los coeficientes
porque los coeficientes son
todos números reales en este caso.
Si hacemos uso de los
valores de seno y coseno de antes en la lección
junto con algunas simetrías, podemos expresar estas probabilidades
como se muestra aquí
en la última columna.
Ahora, lo que realmente nos importa
es la probabilidad de que ganen, y recuerda que, en el caso en que X e Y son ambos cero,
ganan si A y B son iguales y pierden si A y B no son iguales.
Si calculamos esas probabilidades, encontramos que la probabilidad
de que A y B sean iguales es la suma de este número y este número,
que es igual a dos más
raíz de dos todo sobre cuatro, que es aproximadamente el 85%.
La probabilidad de que A y B no sean iguales es dos menos raíz de dos todo sobre cuatro, que naturalmente es uno menos la cantidad
que acabamos de calcular, así que
ganan con probabilidad aproximada del 85% en este caso.
Hay tres casos más a considerar, pero todos son muy similares a este,
en el caso en que X es igual
a cero e Y es igual a uno, Bob aplica U menos pi sobre ocho en lugar de U pi sobre ocho,
los valores en las
fórmulas cambian un poco, pero terminamos con exactamente
las mismas probabilidades que tuvimos en el caso anterior.
Cuando X es cero e Y es uno, Alice y Bob aún ganan
cuando A y B son iguales, así que tenemos exactamente la
misma probabilidad de ganar
que antes.
En el tercer caso, cuando X es igual a uno e Y es igual a cero, tenemos
una situación similar, los ángulos son diferentes,
pero tienen exactamente
la misma relación entre
sí, y de hecho, obtenemos exactamente el
mismo vector que obtuvimos en el caso anterior.
Así que las probabilidades son las mismas y también lo es la probabilidad de ganar.
El último caso es un poco
diferente, como cabría esperar, porque la condición de victoria
es diferente en este caso.
Cuando X e Y son ambos iguales a uno, Alice y Bob ganan cuando
A y B son diferentes.
El método básico es el mismo, aunque los ángulos son diferentes, esta vez obtenemos este vector aquí
y puedes verificarlo realizando las restas necesarias.
Las probabilidades finalmente sí cambian, y si buscamos los valores que necesitamos, vemos que las probabilidades
han cambiado
de posición respecto a antes, así que esta vez es la probabilidad
de que A no sea igual a B la que es mayor de las dos,
pero eso está bien porque en este caso, Alice y Bob ganan cuando
A y B no son iguales.
Así que una vez más, ganan con
probabilidad aproximada del 85%.
Dado que ganan en todos
los casos con la misma probabilidad, que es dos más raíz de dos
todo sobre cuatro o aproximadamente el 85%,
esa es la probabilidad
de que ganen en general.
Eso es mejor de lo que puede lograr cualquier estrategia clásica para este juego, y eso es
lo que lo hace interesante.
Esta resulta ser la
probabilidad de victoria óptima para cualquier estrategia cuántica, no
puedes hacerlo mejor que esto usando ningún estado entrelazado.
Ese hecho se conoce como la desigualdad de Tsirelson, lleva el nombre de Boris
Tsirelson quien la demostró por primera vez, y según mi conocimiento fue
una de las primeras personas
en describir este ejemplo como un juego. En caso de que el análisis
que acabamos de realizar parezca un poco misterioso,
es posible pensarlo
de forma geométrica, lo cual podría ayudarte a
tener una mejor intuición sobre la elección de los ángulos.
Específicamente, si usamos la
fórmula que ves aquí, que podemos deducir fácilmente
de las expresiones
que ya encontramos para los
productos internos involucrados, entonces podemos expresar alternativamente
las probabilidades de los distintos resultados posibles de
la medición
en los cuatro casos de la siguiente manera: primero, si X, Y es igual a cero, cero, entonces estas son las probabilidades
de los distintos resultados de la medición, y tienes que pensar o volver a revisar el análisis
que acabamos de realizar para concluir eso usando nuestra fórmula.
Aquí, podemos ver los
distintos vectores de estado dibujados como estaban antes, y la codificación por colores aquí
es que el azul corresponde
al resultado cero y el rojo
corresponde al resultado uno.
Puedes ver que el ángulo
entre los vectores azules y el ángulo entre los vectores rojos
es relativamente pequeño,
es pi sobre ocho en ambos casos, así que el coseno es relativamente grande, y eso significa que la
probabilidad de que los dos resultados
son iguales es relativamente grande.
En el caso en que X, Y es igual a cero, uno, la situación es similar: los
ángulos entre los vectores del mismo color son pequeños,
así que la probabilidad de
obtener resultados iguales es, de nuevo, relativamente grande.
El tercer caso es similar, y en el cuarto caso,
cuando X, Y es igual a uno, uno, ocurre algo interesante:
esta vez, simplemente por la forma en que
estos vectores han sido elegidos, vemos que los ángulos entre
los vectores del mismo color
son relativamente grandes, y específicamente los ángulos son tres veces
pi sobre ocho en ambos casos.
Esto significa que la probabilidad
de que los resultados de la medición sean iguales es relativamente pequeña, pero este es el único caso
en que Alice y Bob ganan
cuando sus respuestas difieren,
así que es lo que queremos.
Una vez más, aquí están los vectores: cuando X, Y es igual a cero, cero,
cuando X, Y es igual a cero, uno,
cuando X, Y es igual a uno, cero,
y cuando X, Y es igual a uno, uno.
Y quizás esta imagen geométrica
ayuda a desarrollar cierta intuición
sobre cómo funciona esta estrategia
y por qué estos distintos ángulos fueron elegidos de la manera en que lo fueron.
Para terminar la lección, haré algunas observaciones breves
sobre el juego CHSH.
Primero, como ya mencioné, este ejemplo no siempre
se describe como un juego.
En la comunidad de física, por ejemplo, es más común que
el ejemplo se describa simplemente como un experimento, en lugar de un juego,
y Alice y Bob se
ven como detectores en lugar de jugadores.
La idea básica de un experimento como este, en el que el entrelazamiento produce
resultados estadísticos incompatibles con
cualquier descripción clásica,
o más generalmente con cualquier
teoría basada en las llamadas variables ocultas locales,
se debe a John Bell, el homónimo de los estados de Bell,
y por eso la gente suele referirse
a experimentos de este tipo como pruebas de Bell.
A veces la gente también
hace referencia al teorema de Bell, que puede formularse de distintas maneras, pero básicamente dice
que la mecánica cuántica
no es compatible con las llamadas teorías de variables ocultas locales.
El juego o desigualdad CHSH es esencialmente un ejemplo muy claro y elegante
de una prueba de Bell,
y puedes ver este ejemplo como
una prueba o demostración del teorema de Bell.
La segunda observación es que el juego CHSH nos ofrece una forma de verificar experimentalmente que la teoría de la información cuántica
es una teoría precisa. Podemos configurar experimentos que implementen el juego CHSH,
incluyendo el tipo de
estrategia basada en entrelazamiento que acabo de describir, y
comprobar si funciona, y funciona.
Esto nos da un alto
grado de confianza en que el entrelazamiento es real, y a diferencia de las quizás
vagas o poéticas formas
en que intentamos explicar
el entrelazamiento, el juego o experimento CHSH
nos brinda una forma concreta
y verificable de observar el entrelazamiento.
Si eso suena importante,
es porque lo es, y el Premio Nobel de Física de 2022
reconoce exactamente esto.
El premio fue otorgado a
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, quien es la C en CHSH, y Anton Zeilinger
por experimentos con fotones entrelazados que establecieron la violación
de las desigualdades de Bell, o en otras palabras, que
demostraron que las estrategias cuánticas
del tipo que describí realmente funcionan y superan a las estrategias clásicas.
Y si te interesa
aprender más sobre esto, te animo a ver
el video sobre el Teorema de Bell de mi colega Olivia Lanes,
aquí mismo en el canal de YouTube de Qiskit.
Y por último, el tema de los
juegos no locales en general es verdaderamente fascinante, y es
un área activa de investigación
que une la física,
la informática y las matemáticas puras, y todavía hay muchas
preguntas interesantes
sobre los juegos no locales que
permanecen sin respuesta hasta el día de hoy.
Y ese es el final de la lección cuatro, así como el final de
la unidad uno de la serie sobre los Fundamentos de la Información Cuántica.
La primera lección explicó
cómo funciona la información cuántica para sistemas individuales en aislamiento, y la segunda lección explicó
cómo funciona la información cuántica
para sistemas múltiples,
lo cual surge de forma bastante natural a partir de cómo funciona para sistemas individuales.
La tercera lección presentó
el modelo de circuit cuántico de computación, y en la cuarta lección, analizamos tres ejemplos importantes
que ilustran cosas que
podemos hacer con el entrelazamiento.
En el camino, vimos algunos conceptos matemáticos muy importantes,
incluidos los productos tensoriales y los productos internos, y observamos
algunas limitaciones fundamentales
de la información cuántica.
Espero que te unas a mí en
la próxima unidad de la serie, que tratará sobre algoritmos cuánticos, donde nos enfocaremos en la pregunta
de qué ventajas computacionales
ofrece la información cuántica.
Hasta entonces, adiós.